as we're getting ready to wrap up the
year and we just had a federal holiday
that is a religious holiday there are I
guess there is one religion that does
have the privilege of getting federal
holidays we are going to look at a
number of different elements of religion
we'll look at the attempt from the
Christian right to monopolize religion
we're going to talk about the increasing
secularity in the United States we will
talk about the idea of whether at its
core the United States is or is not a
Christian nation and we would also talk
we will also talk today about hypocrisy
and double standards in religion and
much more so I'm glad that you're here
with us for this special episode as we
approach the end of the year
reminder 2020 may be the most important
year ever for independent media and the
David Pakman show
we are going to have a huge membership
special on January 1 we want to kick the
year off as strongly as possible very
strongly to quote our president so if
you've been thinking about maybe
becoming a supporter if you want to do
it now that we're going to be in an
election year get on our newsletter at
david pakman.com and then on January 1st
you'll get an email with the massive
membership discount special that we are
running to try to kick off the year in
really great shape so sign up for the
newsletter at david pakman.com let's get
right into it today our deep dive into
religion in the United States
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
let's go next to our caller from the
seven one nine area code
who's calling today from seven one nine
this is Lamont hey Lamont what's getting
here me yes I got hey David I'm a big
fan of the show I was a Bernie Sanders
delegate in 2016 and I am still
supporting him today I am also though a
Christian and a socialist and that kind
of puts me in kind of a dichotomized
position my question was I believe that
Jesus was a liberal revolutionary hmm
and I that's that's kind of a different
opinion but Jesus overturned tables
because of corruption and the story of
the Good Samaritan I think coincides
with Bernie Sanders example look of
health care that helps should be given
to anyone who needs it even if that
person who needs it happens to be your
enemy that it's a light it's not a
privilege and so I guess my question is
why does the right seem to have a
monopoly on religious principles even
though you know the person is
representing the right right now and
Donald Trump seems to completely disavow
anything you know any of the core
tenants even if like Christianity I
think that Jesus was a lot more like
Bernie yeah basically two reasons in the
way there's two reasons for that
the reason number one is called being
first and reason number two is called
abortion so what I mean by that is that
the the right and the evangelical
Christian community specifically became
intertwined with the Republican Party
decades ago and so oftentimes when
something happens first would there's a
first mover advantage and even though
you know as a non-religious person
myself and someone who was raised you
know culturally Jewish it really doesn't
matter to me what it is anyone believes
Jesus thought did or felt I would agree
with you that if you look at the
teachings you can very reasonably come
away with the perspective you're coming
away with about Jesus Christ
now the other element of this is just
abortion which is the reason that the
evangelical Christian community was tied
in so early with the Republican Party
happened to be very tightly knit around
particularly the issue of abortion there
are many many one or two voters who just
care about abortion so when they hear
you
talk about Lamont you know healthcare or
whatever else it seems like Jesus would
be more on the side of the left
they just say abortion abortion abortion
abortion and that is a very thing to say
I mean it works it worked for decades
you're right for sure but hey thanks for
your thanks for your perspective on this
one David I appreciate your your work
all right Lamont appreciate the phone
call hope to hear from you again thank
you so much very interesting new study
about religious groups in the United
States that I want to discuss with you
the fastest growing religious group in
the country is no religion in other
words people who don't associate with
any particular religion and this is not
a new trend this is actually something
that we've been seeing for a while every
time pew the pew Religion Center does
this report on I believe it's a yearly
basis and we're actually seeing the
increased number of people not
affiliated with religion have real
measurable impact so churches are
closing all around the country or are
having to merge communities that used to
have six churches if you can imagine it
in some cases are merging and combining
and end up sometimes with only two or
three churches we're seeing more
political candidates than ever not
professing a religion many at the local
level more at the state level notably
Kyrsten Sinema who recently has taken
over victory of her Senate seat from
Arizona over Republican martha mcsalley
the first senator to not profess a
religion so we're seeing this more and
more and the Pew Research Center as I
mentioned again has their study on this
issue out and not surprisingly when we
break these results down by age the
younger you are the more likely you are
to select none as your religion if
looking at the results here as we are
together you'll notice that the Silent
Generation born between 28 and 45 has
nearly 90 percent of its constituents
professing a religion whereas baby
boomers and more so Generation X and
more so older Millennials and even more
so younger Millennials at 30
6% profess that they are not affiliated
with any religion when people are
interviewed about having left typically
it's their Christian Church merely from
a from a numbers perspective most people
in the u.s. at least nominally identify
as Christian when they identify with a
religion people are asked well why did
you leave sometimes they talk about you
know the teachings don't relate to real
life I don't feel like there's any
connection between the teachings and and
my actual life or the rituals don't mean
anything to me or I actually am just
bored or uninterested in the rituals
there's a lot of that but I actually
have a more sort of evolutionary
perspective on the fading of religion
Pat for me it's sort of like a survival
of the fittest or natural selection kind
of approach to the fading of religion in
the United States of America
historically survival has been very
accurately predicted by the ability of
individuals and groups to cooperate if
this sin it can include in small numbers
this can also include in large numbers
and one of the big distinguishing
factors between Homo sapiens and earlier
humans and Homo sapiens and other
species is that Homo sapiens can
cooperate in very large numbers in
flexible ways so to give you counter
examples chimpanzees can cooperate
flexibly they can cooperate in foraging
or hunting or building shelters simple
shelters in some cases whatever but they
can only do that in small groups like
chimpanzees can't organize themselves in
a group of 500 these are an example of a
species that can coordinate in huge
numbers beehives with thousands of bees
they can coordinate but only inflexibly
on very narrow tasks if bees all of a
sudden need to coordinate 5,000 bees to
file a tax return I mean it's a dumb
example but on something something
bigger they're not able to do it and
humans can cooperate flexibly in large
numbers years ago many many years ago
being part of a religious group in
priest your chances of survival people
who help you religion increased
collaboration for in-group members we
know that that's the case and therefore
you actually had a higher chance of
survival of living long enough to have
children and pass along your genes that
is now less likely to happen you're not
as likely to suffer in 2018 as a result
of being unable to cooperate with
mankind because you're not part of a
religious group it's less necessary it's
less advantageous in 2018 to be part of
a religious group it's no longer an
issue of survival not to be religious if
you look even today at places where
you're less likely to survive as an
atheist there are fewer atheists the
evolutionary advantage to religious
belief still exists in some places like
look at a country Yemen is an example in
Yemen the population says that religion
is extraordinarily important to them
something like 98 99 percent of the
population says religion is
extraordinarily important in Yemen there
probably is a measurably higher chance
of dying before reproducing if you're
not religious contrast that with
someplace like Norway or Sweden some of
the least religious countries in the
world there's no real advantage to
religion in the survival sense there's
no cooperation advantage in Norway or
Sweden to being part of a church or a
religious group so we can look at this a
few different ways yes the more we learn
about how the world works the more that
science explains things about the world
the decreased need for religion is
noticed and that is a factor but there's
also this other sort of evolutionary
angle and there is one concern here Pat
which is that religion being none is
fine but if people are replacing
religion with this vague New Age not
really religion but pretty horrible
ideas connected to pseudoscience that's
something I would be very careful about
you are you saying that I should return
all the JTAG
I bought from the GUP website Gweneth
Paltrow website yeah no more vaginal
steaming Pat we've got to stop that it's
extraordinarily dangerous and you need
to tell everybody in your family who's
doing it that they need to stop right
away and we're kind of kidding but there
are a lot of really bad ideas right now
under the umbrella not of organized
religious belief but more sort of
agnostic teachings and and anti-vaccine
sentiment the pseudoscience stuff that
Pat's bringing up that's based on or
advertised on Gwyneth Paltrow's website
goop the type of garbage that dr. oz
promotes it's really important to keep
an eye on that but the trend with
organized religion is very clear it's
dwindling in the United States and the
biggest upside for me like you know you
can say David we should care about
people believing things without evidence
no matter whether they're doing it
privately or publicly or both fine we
can argue it's not good for people to
literally believe that if you eat shrimp
you're going to hell or whatever right I
mean whatever the teachings are the
biggest upside for me though is in the
end if people believe whatever they
believe privately if it doesn't impact
what they want to have happen in the
public sphere if they are okay with
total separation of church and state I
don't really care what they believe
privately although I might disagree with
it the upside for me of more people in
the United States professing none as
their religion is that it should allow
it to be easier for our elected
officials to be much more clear much
more direct much more black-and-white on
the issue of secularism meaning a total
separation of church and state and that
that's a good thing because that's
actually a principle the country was
founded on and now here's my question to
you or my proposal to you if you're
hearing me tell this story of people
moving away from religion in the United
States and you think it's bad if you
think it would be better for people in
the United States to remain more
religious or to move back towards
religion please get in touch with me and
let me know why why is it bad
that people are moving away from
religion in the United States I want to
hear from you we will also ask for
thoughts on this via our Instagram
account
instagram.com slash david pakman show
make sure you're following us there and
also follow me on instagram at david
pakman you can find behind the scenes
pictures of the new studio and much more
we will take a quick break what a
program we have for you today the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com I received a really
interesting email from Russell this week
who said it would be interesting to
discuss that Donald Trump appears to be
the first truly atheist president of the
United States but for whatever reason
it's not really being discussed and
maybe just as importantly the
evangelical right-wing Christians still
voted for Donald Trump over Hillary
Clinton and this is a really interesting
topic because there's a few different
angles to it first of all Trump does
appear to be at minimum completely
non-religious in the sort of dogmatic
belief sense if not an out-and-out
atheist but it's just not been part of
the narrative around Donald Trump and I
would argue that the reason it's not
been part of the narrative is because
it's wholly irrelevant to Donald Trump's
governance and also because Donald Trump
took the correct position on abortion
for those who vote based on religion
that is all that matters Trump's
personal religiosity much like Trump's
personal history with women
much like Trump's personal history with
all sorts of other stuff that you
wouldn't think would appeal to the
evangelical vote does not matter as long
as Donald Trump takes what they believe
to be the correct position on the issue
of abortion so let's first go through
the case for believing that Donald Trump
is an atheist or agnostic or
non-religious number one there's really
been no mention of Donald Trump's
holiday plans when it comes to church
services around Christmas or whatever
other holiday
there's no mentions of Donald Trump's
use of the White House Chapel or the
Camp David Chapel I mean we just never
hear about any of it whatsoever
number two there have been no references
to Trump's church membership in New York
City throughout his entire life other
than I believe it was in South Carolina
during the campaign Trump said that he's
a Presbyterian Protestant and that he
goes to marble Collegiate Church as
often as he can which seemed like a lie
especially since marble Collegiate
Church in Manhattan is reformed not
press
Batarian and most people who go to a
church regularly and our religious know
what the religious denomination is of
the church that they're going to it'd be
sort of weird not to know your own
religion that's strange the church also
said that Donald Trump is not an active
member of that church so that just
seemed like a pandering lie George W
Bush George HW Bush's funeral you might
recall that Donald Trump clearly didn't
know the religious songs and the prayers
or whatever it was that was being sung
he the other presidents and their
significant others were singing those
songs confidently and Donald Trump had
no clue what was going on now that could
be just Trump's general ignorance it
could be his lack of reading ability
which we've talked about but
coincidentally it's religious stuff that
Donald Trump seems to be clueless about
when he was asked about Bible verses he
claimed that the Bible was one of his
favorite books along with the art of the
deal but when he was asked again well
what's one of your favorite verses he
says I wouldn't want to get into it
because it's very personal and I don't
really want to get into specific Bible
verses but then in a different moment he
had his infamous 2 Corinthians moment
that made absolutely no sense and people
who know about Corinthians said 2
Corinthians is not the way anybody who
is actually familiar with religious
texts would cite it so it's actually
unclear only because of Trump's
ignorance right on the one hand Trump
might just be ignorant about religion in
the same sense that he's ignorant about
so many other things without actually
being an atheist or a non-believer on
the other hand if this were any other
person who exhibited the characteristics
I've just told you we would say oh yeah
that's absolutely an atheist now
interestingly even if Trump is an
atheist it doesn't really seem that he
would be the first atheist president
there are a number of presidents that
are believed to have been atheists even
if they didn't say it publicly in those
words which in at times passed in the
United States would have been
particularly problematic so you have
Thomas Jefferson Jefferson was accused
of being an atheist as a campaign
strategy by his opponents but it's
likely that he was a deist and a free
thinker so not an atheist per se but
very non rule
relative to the sort of cultural and
religious climate of the time Abraham
Lincoln people around Lincoln including
William Herndon said that Lincoln's
religious views were complicated and
that at times he was an atheist and that
Lincoln was really a follower of Darwin
not of religion although publicly
Lincoln still did pay lip service to
being a religious person you have
ulysses s grant not affiliated with any
church considered to be a Methodist but
never baptized went to church rarely
reportedly only did it to appease his
wife who was religious and in his death
note to his wife he mentioned meeting
her in another world which suggests at
least some belief in an afterlife but
significant speculation that he was not
a religious man and then you have
William Howard Taft William Howard Taft
was described as a Unitarian often sort
of like what we would call non-religious
Christianity or hipster Christianity or
less religious Christianity Christian
atheism so to speak once Taft said I
believe in God I do not believe in the
divinity of Christ so sort of judge it
for the times and evaluate as you will
but the bottom line here is number one
most importantly Donald Trump is still a
terrible president whether he's
religious or not number two
Donald Trump still panders to religious
groups recognizing that they are a
predominantly important significantly
important voting bloc if you were
running as a Republican he still has
opening prayers at events he
participated in the anti-abortion march
march for life I believe it's called
claiming I don't know if we believe it
but he claims to have had an awakening
relatively late in his life well into
adulthood about a kid that was born
after the mother thought about having an
abortion but didn't and that that
changed him from being a lifelong
pro-choice individual to being
anti-abortion coincidentally very
shortly before deciding to run for
president so this is why it's
functionally irrelevant
their Trump's deeply held beliefs are
religious or not this is similar to what
I said earlier in the week people say
well we don't know if deep down Trump is
a racist we don't know if deep down
Trump is xenophobic his public presence
as president of the United States as
commander-in-chief of the United States
is a presence that is both racist and
xenophobic he is functionally racist and
xenophobic he is coalescing racists and
xenophobes around his nationalist
ideology and his campaign ideas and all
of the rhetoric that he's espousing so
does it matter deep down whether Trump
is actually racist in his heart of
hearts in his mind of minds no it
doesn't matter and similarly I would
make the case that yeah I do believe
that Donald Trump partially just out of
complete and total ignorance of religion
and partially because religion has never
been important to him he's probably a
non-believer he is probably at minimum
an agnostic if I had to guess deep down
but it doesn't really matter because
publicly he is functionally pandering to
the religious right in basically the
same way that most Republican candidates
and presidents and elected officials in
the House and Senate have done and it
makes the question of his deep down
sincerely held religious beliefs
practically irrelevant from the point of
view of governance and from the point of
view of what it is that he is going to
signify to evangelicals when he says I'm
against abortion despite the fact that
he's had the sexual assault allegations
and alleged rape of his ex-wife and the
affairs and the videos with Jeffrey
Epstein touching women on the rear end
does not clear that that's what they
want it doesn't really matter because
he's functionally taken the correct
position on the most important religious
voting issue and that is the issue of
abortion if you disagree with me that
Trump is likely not religious let me
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman if you
disagree with me that his sincerely held
beliefs actually do matter as much as or
more than the public representation on
issues of importance to religion then
let me know basically if you disagree
with anything in my analysis I'd like to
hear from you I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show we're going to open the phone lines
shortly we are going to answer audience
questions and a lot of very relevant and
important topics to be discussed on
today's show the david pakman show at
david pakman.com welcome back to the
david pakman show it's great to welcome
back to the program today Andrew Seidel
who's a civil rights and constitutional
attorney with the Freedom From Religion
Foundation where he serves as the
director of strategic response works to
keep state and church separate his new
book is the founding myth why Christian
nationalism is unamerican Andrew so
great to have you back on thank you for
having me on it really is a pleasure I
appreciate it David so we recently did a
story which was called something like
the founding fathers were progressive
and you should be too and with without
getting into the sort of politics of it
there is this idea which was part of
that story that we did our best to
debunk which is the idea that because
all of the founding fathers were
Christian that there is either some
explicit or implicit reasoning behind
saying the United States is
fundamentally a Christian nation now
before we get to part two of that the
first question we have to ask is were
the founding fathers actually Christian
what we found is that while they were
mostly deists they were not actually
mostly Christian as is often described
but my question to you is does that even
really matter in figuring out whether
the United States should have this sort
of motto or umbrella term of being a
Christian nation is the is the religion
of the founding fathers even relevant to
that my contention is that it is not and
this is the argument that I try to make
in the founding myth it's a really
interesting conversation and it's
fascinating to delve into the beliefs of
the founders but when you're talking
about well is this actually a Christian
nation it doesn't matter so if it let's
say let's just agree for
second for the sake of argument that all
the founders were these bible-believing
Jesus rose from the dead Christians you
would still then have to connect those
beliefs to the founding of the United
States and just because somebody is
religious their religion doesn't claim
ownership over every other idea that
their mind generates you know for
instance blue jeans were invented by two
Jewish guys but we don't go around
calling them Jewish blue jeans they're
just blue jeans
well you share some of the YouTube
comments I get before you say nobody's
doing that but yeah I don't think we
shouldn't be doing that
yeah and I don't think we can judge
everything by the YouTube comments
because they do yes yeah it generates
quick down there sorry everybody
the larger point I think is you would
still have to connect it to the founding
and you can't do that and when you look
at what the founders talked about and
believed and actually wrote into the
founding documents they really did
believe in the separation of state and
church they were trying to keep religion
out of government and government out of
religion and those were kind of that was
kind of one of the big ideas that was
unique to America it was the first time
that that had been put into practice and
it was I mean it's the it's the American
invention then probably our biggest
contribution to political science and we
ought to be proud of that fact as
Americans proud of the separation of
state and church ended proud of its
progressive leanings I think as well so
if if indeed the original founders were
did not have this belief of sort of
Christian nationalism as the basis for
the United States of America and now
there is a wing of the American
political sphere that does have that
belief at some point something made that
belief start among a certain wing of the
American political sphere where did that
start where did it come from where did
this idea this talking point that became
very prevalent in certain political
circles start from if not with the
actual founders that and that's a
fascinating question so Christian
national Christian nationalism is really
this idea that the United States not
only was founded as a Judea as a
Christian nation but it was founded on
judeo-christian principles yeah
and put that Dakota to that is that it
needs to return to those principles so
really and that is the best the driving
motivating force for Christian
nationalists they're trying to get this
return this and it's it's Golden Age
thinking really accept that the problem
for them is that we never were founded
as a Christian nation so you saw it
really ride the rise of Christian
nationalism began with sort of the rise
of the moral majority and it wouldn't it
didn't really get that name Christian
nationalism until the mid 2000s and it
was always sort of this impotent little
sideshow on the fringes of conservative
politics on the fringes of conservative
religion but that all changed with the
2016 election because Donald Trump rode
a wave of Christian nationalism into the
highest office in the land I mean he is
not president in spite of his Christian
nationalist leanings and rhetoric but
because of that Christian nationalist
rhetoric
yeah and that gets us to making this
distinction which is an important one
between someone between Christianity so
to speak and Christian nationalism
because I think as many have obviously
pointed out if you compare Donald
Trump's philosophy and the way he's
lived his life to the sort of Christian
Bible you see a lot of contradictions
there you see a lot of problems but
ultimately most evangelical Christians
did vote for Donald Trump and it seems
to me Andrew and correct me if I'm wrong
wrong that underlying it is that even
though Donald Trump may not have
personally lived his life as a Christian
the nationalistic undertones of Donald
Trump's campaign are in line with this
broader idea of Christian nationalism
that seems to be kind of separate from
one identifying as a Baptist or or as an
evangelical for example know that and
that's absolutely right and it's really
important that people understand that
the number one predictor of whether or
not somebody would vote for Donald Trump
in the 2016 election was not political
party and it was not their religion
I wasn't even whether or not they were
racist socioeconomic status none of that
the number one predictor was whether or
not somebody believed that the United
States was a Christian nation so
Christian nationalism was the best
indicator of whether or not somebody was
would have been a Donald Trump voter in
the 2016 election that dad
pretty ironclad now Andrew Whitehead out
of the University of Clemson has done a
number of studies on this it's it's very
clear so Trump wasn't tapping into even
the Republican Party or even into the
evangelical movement
there's just happens to be a huge
overlap between those two and Christian
nationalism that was really what he was
tapping into to win this election
what about that's a little more
amorphous idea of the you you alluded to
it already
judeo-christian values which is we can
we can slice and dice the exact
religions of the founders we can talk
about separation of church and state in
some kind of formal or legal sense but
it's undeniable some will say that the
sort of fundamental moral infrastructure
of the United States was based on the
judeo-christian and really - that means
Christian because there were almost no
Jews who were part of this group mostly
Christian people Christian Christian
inside in terms of the values again not
in terms of necessarily identifying as
Baptist or whatever the case may be who
said we want to leave England and settle
the new world in order to have full
religious freedom how do we take on that
argument which is a little bit more
nebulous and blurry and and that's
exactly what I try to do in the founding
myth and it is more nebulous and blurry
and that's why it's the fallback
position if you can push back on were
not founded as a Christian nation the
next argument you always get is well I
really meant we were founded on
judeo-christian principles and that's
really what the founding myth pushes
back on and that's what what I did was I
actually compared the judeo-christian
principles from the Bible I looked at
every one of the Ten Commandments and
then I compared those to the founding
principles the United States to those
elements of political science and
political philosophy that the founders
used to actually build this country and
I what I discovered was not just that
judeo-christian principles didn't
influence the founding but that they're
fundamentally opposed to the founding of
the United States what give like a one
or two examples of that if you can I
mean the best example would be let's
just focus on the first of first
commandment
right the first commandment is I am the
Lord your God you shall have no other
gods before me it runs completely
counter to one of our founding
principles religious liberty you can
worship no
God you can worship a hundred gods you
get to have free religious liberty in
this in this country and if you were to
follow the Ten Commandments you only get
to worship that biblical God and that's
it so there's this fundamental conflict
so it's not only that we weren't founded
on judeo-christian values or principles
but it's a good thing we weren't
otherwise we wouldn't have the values
and the freedoms that we so cherished
today so if we decided to cherry-pick
only the areas in which maybe there does
seem to be significant overlap between
the sort of founding values in
Christianity just as a thought
experiment for a second we then get to
the problem of sort of correlation and
causation and I've actually heard a
number of thinkers point out that just
because most of the individuals who made
big advancements in for example stone
tools metal tools maybe is a better
example were adherents to a certain
religion that doesn't really give us any
causal case for the religion being a
factor it may just be that at the time
there was a sort of default to a
particular religious belief so to speak
a lot of the values that do seem to
overlap between the founders of the US
and Christianity are values that existed
much more than 5,000 years ago in human
societies anyway some of the question is
are they really even Christian values
and that's a really excellent point and
it is one that I do make in the founding
myth in a couple different places one
thing that we often hear is well the
United States is it was founded on the
Golden Rule and I think that's a hard
argument to make actually but I just
assume for the sake of argument in the
book that that is true but then the
Naquin next question is well is the
golden rule really a Christian principle
and my argument is that it's not this is
a universal human principle that every
successful society we know of has
developed on its own I mean a two three
four year old child can understand the
idea of reciprocal morality it's it's
really not a difficult concept and to
allow Christian Christianity or even
Christian nationalism to claim it as its
own is is to me a form of arrogance that
that I don't think we should allow to
stand can you talk a little bit about
slogans like in God
we trust on money or one nation under
God or the addition of a reference to
God in the Pledge of Allegiance and the
role that those slogans have in
perpetuating these ideas of the United
States as a Christian nation I mean they
have a huge role in perpetuating that
myth and the role is deliberate so you
know one thing that I think maybe our
site is pretty good at when it comes to
pushing back on those those mottos is
pointing out that none of those are from
the founding generation but then we tend
to leave it at that and in the founding
myth I really wanted to go beyond that I
so I explore how these phrases entered
our vernacular and it turns out that
they were deliberately put there during
times of national fear and strife when
you had a few very few a handful in each
case Christian's Christian nationalists
we would call them today trying to use
their public office to promote their
personal religion so you know you have
this happening during the height of the
Civil War when the country is literally
tearing itself apart and people aren't
paying attention to what's being
inscribed on the coinage and yeah it's
basically three guys responsible for
getting it on there at that point the
same thing was happening in the 1950s
where we ended up with the National Day
of Prayer and under God in the pledge
that it was this time of national fear
and so it's not just that they're taking
advantage of a country that's scared and
fearful but they're also wiping out
unifying sentiments with religion which
tends to be really divisive you know and
so our original de facto motto was a
pluribus unum from one people or from
one from many people one nation from
many states one country and they wiped
that out within god we trust'
and the same thing happened with the
Pledge of Allegiance it used to read One
Nation individual indivisible which is
this beautiful sentiment and then
they're literally dividing the
indivisible with God so it's not just
they're taking advantage of times of
fear and strife and then they're wiping
out unifying sentiments to promote their
personal religion this seems way bigger
to me than partisan politics in the
sense that okay I mean there are
candidates whose philosophy is
more of a departure from the sort of
thinking that gets you to Christian
nationalism so there are differences I'm
not pretending that Trump and Biden and
Bernie are all sort of like the same on
this but but in a sense this is a much
bigger cultural thing this relates to
the courts and the Supreme Court in ways
that that kind of transcend many decades
so how does something like this change
in a country when who we elect is only
like a small piece of it you're
absolutely right and right now it's
infecting all kinds of policy
immigration policy we saw it in the
Muslim ban education policy Betsy DeVos
is essentially trying to dismantle
public education all of those are on the
back of Christian nationalism our
foreign policy we're seeing and you are
right that courts judges and not just
Trump judges are deciding cases based on
some of the myths and the lies that I
try to expose in my book but you're also
right to say that it's bigger because at
its most basic level what this is is an
attempt to redefine what it is to be an
American they are trying to say that to
be an American you have to be a
Christian and to be a Christian is to be
an American and once they've redefined
the American identity like that they're
going to redefine all of our laws
accordingly and to me that is one of the
central reasons why I say that Christian
nationalism is unamerican it's not just
that those judeo-christian principles
often are directly opposed to our
founding values it's that this entire
movement is meant to redefine what it is
to be an American in an unamerican way
we've been talking a lot about the
content of Andrew sidles new book the
founding myth why Christian nationalism
is unamerican but there's much more of
great stuff in it Andrew always great to
talk to you and I really appreciate your
time David thank you so much it's always
a pleasure the david pakman show at
david pakman
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
okay I've got some clips to play for you
today from a recent interview that
right-winger ben shapiro did on Joe
Rogan's podcast we could do 30 minutes
on all of the caveats about Joe Rogan
and Ben Shapiro we can talk about Joe
Rogan effectively according to some
serving as a gateway to the alt-right we
can talk about the ways in which ben
shapiro
appears to be very informed and
convincing but often says things that
don't make sense I've said before if you
listen really closely to ben shapiro you
will often realize that even though he's
speaking confidently and he's speaking
quickly that what he's saying is
actually not making that much sense and
i have a couple of really funny examples
of that and Joe Rogan I don't even know
that Joe Rogan realized how much he
exposed ben shapiro in the clips that
i'm going to play for you today so to
set it up this gets to a portion of the
interview between ben shapiro and joe
rogan where i guess i would say it's
about ben Shapiro's religious beliefs
and Joe Rogan's asking questions about
Ben Shapiro's Orthodox Judaism and
mostly they're talking about
homosexuality which I'm going to get to
a little bit later in the clip but Joe
and Ben sort of agree that there are
some historical reasons why things
became Commandments in the Old Testament
for example they agree that there are
some historical realities at the time
which explained to us like for example
the Bible mentions man shall not lie
with another man or whatever the phrase
is I don't even care but the the line
that's pointed to that people point to
is saying homosexuality is bad
that wasn't in the Bible because the
people who wrote the Bible thought in a
thousand years maybe there will be gay
people it was there because they saw gay
people at the time and they decided
we're gonna put something in the Bible
about it okay the the the example
doesn't really matter but the idea is
the Bible reflects things that were
happening at the time so Joe Rogan
brings up a sort of naturalistic
explanation for why eating pork is not
Oh
in Judaism it's also not okay in Islam
the same analysis would sort of apply
related to the cooking temperature of
pork and bacteria and whatever you'll
hear it in a second and ben shapiro says
very clearly he doesn't like
naturalistic explanations for this stuff
check it out and pay really close
attention here to what ben shapiro says
like the very reason to have a
commandment is because certain people in
your community are behaving in a
particular way presumably right there's
no commandment not to take your head and
shove it in a meat grinder well this is
also the argument against pork that's
because they didn't understand
trichinosis they understand you have to
cook the meat to 145 degrees and pork
parasites which are very dangerous for
people so i'm not a huge fan of
naturalistic explanations for religion i
think that's a good one though for pork
i mean i don't know like i think you
could make an argument maybe okay
ben shapiro says very clearly he's
against naturalistic explanations for
religion meaning he doesn't like
explaining religious precepts with sort
of real-world
justifications from nature ben shapiro
said very clearly he's against that fine
so then about 90 seconds go by okay this
next clip is from 90 seconds after what
I just played for you and ben shapiro
gives a naturalistic explanation for
Moses parting the Red Sea he just said
he's not into naturalistic explanations
and here he gives a naturalistic
explanation 90 seconds later do you
think I resurrect no that's not that's
not a Jewish belief
oh Christ one-shot yeah no any miracles
no not by Jesus and then there there
one's the old women yeah you've got
Moses splitting the sea and all that
what do you think I've been there what
do I think happened there yeah well I'll
go with my mana D and explanation that
there was it I mean it says in the Bible
there was a strong east wind so there
was a naturalistic explanation for a
physical phenomenon that makes sense I
mean that's what Maimonides is
constantly trying to do is read nature
back into the Bible mmm yeah he says
it's the miracle of Moses parting the
Red Sea and he naturalistically explains
it
in the Red Sea area which is a very
common naturalistic explanation for the
parting of the Red Sea in the old
testament which he just said he's not in
favor of he's not in favor of those
types of explanations except all of a
sudden when he is and this reminds me of
naturalistic explanations for Noah's Ark
if you talk to some religious people
about Noah's Ark they'll say no you know
we've sort of identified where there
were floods at the time based on
geological records and here is how it
all could have worked so on and so forth
never explains how some of the species
need salt water and some need fresh
water and how did they get all of that
onto the ark for the time it had to be
there it doesn't explain how there are
carnivorous animals and if you only had
two of each species didn't any of them
get eaten did you start with more than
two and they were eaten down to two or
did carnivorous animals get fed some
kind of Soylent or vegan diet during
none of that stuff is explained but at
least the the specifics of the flood are
sometimes explained naturalistically
with Noah's Ark this is the same thing
here naturalistically explaining the
parting of the Red Sea after saying he
doesn't like naturalistic explanations
now I know some people will say David
hold on
ben shapiro says Maimonides gives that
explanation it doesn't matter ben
shapiro said he's not for naturalistic
explanations of religious stories or
miracle or miracles or phenomena and
then 90 seconds later he insta flips on
himself and it was a missed opportunity
actually for Joe to call him out on that
so then they get back to homosexuality
and to Dave Reubens marriage to his
husband Dave Rubin is a cultural critic
and political commentator who engages in
the battle of ideas where the free
market allows the best ideas to float to
the top sort of like fat on on milk or
butter or whatever anyway they get to
Dave Reubens
marriage which Ben Shapiro has been
saying for a while how he would not go
to Dave's room Dave Reubens wedding or I
guess wouldn't have gone if they had
been friends at the time I don't know
that they knew each other at the time
but he'd still have Dave and his husband
over for dinner because going to the
wedding
goes against his religious beliefs but I
guess having them to dinner doesn't and
Joe Rogan just exposes the idiocy idiocy
of it so easily right and one of the
things that I the reason I keep coming
back to the governmental regulation
point is because my view is that if your
view of discipline is not my view of
discipline good on you
right like go do what you want to do
like I've never had a conversation with
Dave Rubin about about him being a gay
guy right but he did say that you like
wouldn't go to his marriage right well I
said right as a religious person I can't
say I can't actively participate in
something that I consider to be a sin
but I would go out to dinner with Dave
and his husband anytime like my wife and
I would do that of course we'd have him
over to our house with his husband
there's no you don't find any
contradiction between your religious
perspective and your personal
perspective in that regard that you
would though you wouldn't be there for
religious reasons but that you would be
there for personal reasons like if it
wasn't would you go to the after-party
like if you wouldn't go to the wedding
would you go to the after-party anything
that was a celebration of same-sex
marriage no wow so anything but like if
we go to the party no I mean there's a
barbecue the next day you know it's and
again like I'm not sure why I'm not a
good party person so I'm not sure why
anybody would want me at their party
frankly I haven't been to a party with
you but I went to a dinner party with
you that's right we had a great time and
that was a good time that's good that's
a funny picture man that isn't I don't
know what the [ __ ] to think about that
picture we had it's certainly true Eric
and Jordan so Joe Rogan's being sort of
funny about it
he's very pressing Atlee exposing the
absurdity of what ben shapiro is saying
going out to dinner with a gay couple
who you recognize as a gay couple is
recognizing the idea that they are a
couple which his religion considers a
sin it's a very sort of mealy-mouthed
weird gray area to say well I wouldn't
go to the wedding ceremony because then
I would be endorsing something my
religion believes as a sin and I
wouldn't go to the wedding reception and
just have dinner because I would be
recognizing the sin but like a couple
days later I'd go to dinner with them as
a couple which of course is recognized
as a couple which his religion believes
is a sin but that would sort of be okay
in been Shapiro's mind and you know he
says he wouldn't go to anything that
celebrates same-sex marriage I hate to
break it to you but when you go out with
a couple who is married and it's a gay
couple you're effectively celebrating or
at minimum recognizing something that
your religion teaches you is a sin it is
the fence sitting that is so
mealy-mouthed that I found just
laughable here and here Joe Rogan
actually does a really good job when he
says what about the reception what about
a barbecue the day after like at what
point is going to hang out with Dave
Rubin and his husband disconnected
enough from the fact that it's a gay
couple that's married under the law that
you can sort of rationalize it post
facto in a way that feels okay for what
your religion teaches this is why it's
all nonsense and really nice job by Joe
Rogan in exposing it and by the way ben
shapiro is welcome on the show anytime
he's been on before think at this point
he probably I think he's too big for the
David Pakman show at this point he's got
bigger fish to fry
but open invitation for him anytime
follow me on Twitter at D Pakman follow
the show on Twitter at David Pakman show
I would love to hear from you about this
of course last question today hey David
if you had to pick pick a cult to join
which one would it be you've interviewed
people who have left cults many times
over the years and I'm curious if you
had to join one which one would it be
there's really no way to talk about this
without addressing what's the difference
between a religion and a cult there are
some people who say all religions are
cults there are others who sort of come
up with this jokey idea of well
religions are old they've been around
for a long time whereas the cults are
new and that's how you distinguish them
and of course there is something to the
perception of religion versus cult
called based on their age but I don't
know that that's actually fair it's
actually sort of difficult right now for
me to really define religion versus cult
because cult has an understandably
negative sort of pejorative connotation
but when you look at the definitions of
cult versus religion you often find that
the differences are matters of degree
that those characteristics which are
attributed to cults exist in most
religions except to a lesser degree so
I'm gonna admit in answering the
question that we probably need to better
assess exactly when it's a cult and when
it's a religion but my answer is
Mormonism either way I I think that if I
had to join a cult and I know people
will say Mormonism is no cults David the
way I'm interpreting the question I
would probably join Mormonism for the
sole reason that Mormons seem to be
pretty damn successful because they have
really effective networks for working
with each other helping each other build
businesses in a way that most other
communities and cults don't in fact you
often saw the opposite I recently read
about a whole book fantastic by Jeff
Quinn about the Jim Jones cult cult and
Jonestown and one of the things they
didn't get right and I'm using that term
very loosely is that with very few
exceptions they didn't actually generate
this Network where the people that were
part of the cult were living well if I'm
gonna join a cult I at least want to
feel like I'm gonna be in a community
where I'm gonna do really well
personally even if I'm participating in
something that's horrible Mormonism
seems to have that and that may be a
crazy way to decide which cult I would I
would join I also don't think that as
far as cults go Mormonism does too much
in the way of physical violence against
people who don't necessarily want to
participate or become disaffected or
choose to leave although there's there's
probably examples of everything so I'm
ready for the criticism I know people
will say either David you're wrong about
Mormonism they are violent or or they're
not that successful in the world or
Mormonism is just not a cult and I
shouldn't be including it but I answer
the questions the way I understand
to be asked and Mormonism is probably
the cult that I would join on the bonus
show today we will talk about our
upcoming Thanksgiving breaks we will
also address a question I've gotten a
few times given that I am so against the
institution of a royal family and of the
sort of chance of being born you know
into a position of authority in that way
would I respect members of royal
families if I were to meet them we're
gonna talk about that on the bonus show
and also we'll talk about master race
guy this is a story I didn't cover on
the regular show and there's a really
specific reason why and we're gonna
address that on the bonus show two ways
to get instant access to the bonus show
one become a member at WWJ in pac-man
com if you want to save 40 percent off
of your membership you can do that by
using the coupon code this is 20 20 this
is to zero to zero you can also make a
pledge of at least 5 bucks a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
get instant access to the bonus show I
will see you then if not have a good
Thanksgiving we'll be back with new
shows on Monday last audience question
of 2018
David religion is a disaster religion is
damaging how can we make religion
illegal this is a bad idea okay number
one we probably can't make religion
illegal first of all because it's sort
of enshrined in our Constitution
secondly because how do you police what
is in someone's mind which is where
religion exists whether or not you're
going to church you can still be
religious in your mind but this this
doesn't make any sense okay so I don't
think that this is a big topic on on the
left trying to make religion illegal but
to be abundantly clear trying to make
religion illegal is a losing issue
legally it's a losing issue
constitutionally it's a losing issue
politically if you aren't religious and
you don't like religion you think that
organized religion is problematic in
many ways which I do then make the focus
secularism right which
means separation of church and state
making sure that religion is not
influencing civil government and that
when we figure out well what should be
legal in terms of abortion or gay
marriage or stem-cell research we make
those decisions based on science and
empiricism and the material world rather
than because of religious beliefs which
are a self-professed and arbitrary okay
make that the focus that's all great and
with you trying to make religion illegal
is a horrible idea
it is self-sabotage it would never work
and any candidate who runs on anything
even approximating this idea and I know
most people in the audience know this
it's setting themselves up to fail and
is setting up the left assuming it's a
left-wing candidate who proposes this
although I don't see anyone proposing it
to hurt the left so I don't know exactly
the surf source of this question it just
came in from the audience but this is a
terrible idea it would never work don't
do it and on that note I will tell you
that on today's bonus show the last
bonus show of 2018 we will talk about
the government shutdown continuing
likely to stretch into 2019 we will talk
about an incredible electronic electric
transformer explosion that took place in
New York which turned the entire skyline
blue even reported on on the news in my
birth country of Argentina I turned on
the news from Argentina this morning
they were talking about this stunning
video out of New York and very
interestingly in the world of the fake
news battles MSNBC's ratings have topped
fox news for the first time in 18 years
what does it mean should we care what
should we make of it in the world of
independent media all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show get
access by becoming a member at join
pakman.com by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
most recently option number 3 by
becoming a youtube member by clicking
the blue join button on our youtube
channel or on any one of our
YouTube videos talk to you on the bonus
show if you have access if not I will
speak to you in the New Year
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]